alors qu'ils n'y étaient pas préparés
ils ont été propulsés subitement sous le
feu des projecteurs leur aventure n'a
duré qu'un temps avant qu'ils ne
retombent dans l'oubli médiatique alors
Sabrina vous vous avez 28 ans vous
voulez être aujourd'hui comédienne tout
à fait vous êtes célibataire sans
enfants et vous avez été à l'âge de 16
ans donc c'était en
1982 vous avez été élu Miss France
comment à 16 ans une jeune fille de 16
ans vit tout cela
ouf j'ai pas réalisé sur le coup et puis
je crois c'est surtout le lundemain
matin madame de F me téléphone allô
Sabrina réveillez-vous vous êtes en
retard et tout j'avais une nuit parce
que ça s'est terminé très tard en fait
vu qu'il y avait les journalistes la
radio et cetera donc j'avais
pratiquement pas dormi et tout de suite
il fallait que j'aille voir le coiffeur
le maquilleur on devait aller donc à
l'époque c'était l'émission de Bouvard
donc c'était en direct j'avais jamais
fait de télévision de ma vie et ensuite
tout de suite après on est allé donc
c'était au journal de 13h avec Yv rousi
donc pour moi c'était quelque chose ose
d'extraordinaire mais en même temps je
me suis dit est-ce que je vais pas
bégayer je vais pas vous avvez le trac
oui j'avais le trac et en même temps je
me suis dit mais en fait qu'est-ce que
je fais là alors pendant toute cette
année qui a qui a suivi donc vous avez
fait des voyages qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé pour vous bah déjà
donc beaucoup de d'interviews dans la
presse beaucoup de photos est-ce que
vous avez aimé ça ou est-ce que c'était
desplaisants non j'ai j'ai vraiment aimé
ça j'adore faire de la photo pour moi
c'est une passion euh je je je le cache
pas je veux
dire le seul problème peut-être c'est
que ça a été un peu rapide quelque part
tout d'un coup je suis dans Paris ma
jour de France dans la Une de de de tous
les journaux je passe à la télévision
les gens anis me reconnaissent bon c'est
vrai que c'est c'était c'est au départ
c'est c'est pas évident alors tout à
l'heure Tarzan parlait de réaction
parfois négativ autour de lui lorsqu'il
a été médiatisé vous vous étiez au lycée
hein vous dites je pouvais me voir dans
les dans les journaux comment réagissez
vos vos vos amis et et les élèves en
général alors justement c'est c'est
curieux parce que je et ben c'est là où
on voit ses vraies copines et et ses
ennemis alors les les filles qui étaient
proches de moi au contraire me félicité
oh c'est formidable surtout j'avais rien
dit moi j'ai jamais dit je veux faire
ceci cela ils ont découvert
ça mais il y a des gens Ben qui qui qui
qui me disaent ah mais qui critiqu un
petit peu aussi forcément il y avait des
jalousies je pense h ça se ressentait
surtout là c'est là où j'ai eu un petit
peu de mal c'est là où j'ai je me suis
dit je continue l'école ou c'est qu'un
jour j'ai j'ai posé pour un grand
couturier et il présenta le clou de sa
collection et c'est passé dans tous les
journaux donc de France et j'étais un
petit peu allongé sur un canapé mais
d'une façon très très clean quoi et
c'est vrai que c'était un quelque chose
un c'était c'était un buser avec un
petit rond au milieu et c'est vrai que
quand j'étais un petit peu baissé comme
ça sur le divan on voyait un petit peu
mais même pas le sein en fait c'était
vraiment le creux quoi et et comme quand
je suis arrivée au lycée je me
rappellerai toujours tout le monde
criait
elle a posé nu pour dessous je vous
assure c'était assez terrible et
croyez-moi je me suis dit mais attends
tu vas rentrer dans la dans dans la cour
c'est pas possible et je me suis dit bon
j'ai respiré je suis rentré mais c'est
vrai que je crois que c'est le moment de
ma vie le pire je crois vous avez pleuré
ce soir-là comme une petite fille ou
j'ai j'ai pleuré ouais quand je suis
rentré j'ai dit ma mère je m' parlais
toujours je peux plus retourner à
l'école elle m'a dit si si justement il
faut que tu y ailles all et les
professeurs comment ont-ils réagir bon
il y en a qui disaient rien mais bon ils
en pensaient pas moins quoi bon pas tous
négativement mais c'est vrai qu'ils
étaient surpris aussi alors justement
d'être élu Miss France si jeune est-ce
que ça vous a complètement transformé
etchamboulé
euh transformé non je dirais transformer
bon peut-être un petit peu ma vie mais
finalement vous l'avez bien vécu d'être
élu ou ou
ça vous a dérangé par la suite bah
disons que je l'ai bien vécu pour une
chose c'est que bon ça m'a permis de
faire des voyages extraordinairees dans
des conditions fantastiques euh de
rencontrer justement les
personnes des personnalités pourquoi pas
Patrick Hernandez à cette époque là ou
je sais pas mais je veux dire pour moi
c'était quand même quelque chose de
fabuleux parce que j'étais en seconde et
en seconde bon ben à part les élèves
j'allais faire du vélo j'allais faire
j'allais nager j'avais un trainain un
petit peu je dirais quotidienne comme
comme toutes les lycéennes quoi mais
justement ça ne vous a pas vous perturbé
complètement dans vos études au niveau
étude oui bien sûr vous avez arrêté euh
non j'ai continué un petit peu mais
c'est vrai que ah oui ça ça a quand même
arrêtéou ou ou donc ça c'est c'est le
côté négatif reg c'est le côté
négatif sur le coup j'avais peur je me
suis dit tu tu tu tu devrais continuer
bon mais j'avais pas vraiment la tête à
ça non je regrette plus parce que je
réalise surtout maintenant voyez que que
j'aime ce milieu j'aime j'aime j'aime ça
quoi j'en ai besoin votre famille était
était d'accord ça ne les a pas dérangé
euh d'accord non non pas vraiment non
pas ils ont pas recherché non parce que
ma mère c'est vrai que une maman elle a
elle veut voir l'avenir de sa fille
d'une façon positive et c'est vrai que
ça lui a fait peur donc elle s'est dit
qu'est-ce qu'elle va devenir de quoi
elle va vivre quel sera son son travail
donc non pas pas vraiment mais ils ont
rien fait pour m'en empêcher et vous
vous dites
j'aurais préféré faire une carrière de
de comédienne alors est-ce que ça n'a
pas eu un point négatif c'est-à-dire de
vous désigner comme Miss France vous
êtes choisi pour votre physique mais non
pas pour quelque chose que que que vous
faites pour une création est-ce que sur
le long terme ça ne nous a pas joué des
tours euh je pense oui et non au départ
c'est quand même malgré tout une carte
de visite et au moins les gens encore
maintenant oui tout à fait bon oui oui
oui les gens me reçoivent malgré tout
parce que j'ai quand même un petit peu
d'expérience qu'est-ce que vous a
apporté le titre de Miss France Sabrina
qu'est-ce que ça m'a apporté bah déjà
c'est que ça m'a permis de me dire
justement maintenant 12 ans après
euh que ce que que je peux continuer
parce que le le le rêve que le petit
rêve que j'ai toujours eu depuis toute
petite de d'être un petit peu géré dans
la lumière pour moi pu que je viens de
Nice he c'est une petite
province j'ai connu ça donc pourquoi ça
ne reviendrait pas justement qu'est-ce
que vous avez fait après cette année
donc c'est une année un peu de
dans ce que vous racontez complètement
ou ouais sans vraiment avoir conscience
de ce qui se passait et l'année d'après
les années qui ont suivi qu'est-ce que
vous avez fait alors qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait bon déjà j'ai fait 4 ans de théâtre
j'ai fait un petit peu de publicité j'ai
fait beaucoup de photos j'ai fait 2 45
tours
aussi mais tout ça c'est quand même
grâce à Miss France parce
que sans sans cette carte de visite je
pense que je n'aurais jamais eu accès à
tout ça vous avez pu vivre de tout ça
vous avez dû faire des des petits
boulots à côté non justement j'ai j'ai
eu la notion et c'est pour ça que je
crois que j'ai quand même la tête sur
les épaules c'est que j'ai eu ce monde
j'ai connu ce monde de showbsiness et
cetera avec les photos et cetera mais en
même temps non j'ai j'ai toujours
travaillé j'ai fait j'ai été au test
d'accueil j'ai travaillé aussi dans dans
des bureau comme par exemple je
m'occupais de la promotion de d'un
produit de cosmétique capillaire des
choses comme ça donc j'ai fait
l'animation aussi pour des canin
commercial j'ai fait beaucoup de galas
aussi est-ce que ça a été difficile de
passer de cette cette année vous étiez
comme vous dites dans la ère aux années
qui qui ont
suivi un petit peu au début oui c'est
vrai que le coup de les coup de fil coup
de fil oui il y en a beaucoup moins donc
c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu
difficile mais bon je suis hyper jeune
et puis comme j'avais pas mal de
proposition je me suis dit j'en aurais
encore durant les restes de mes années
donc en fait j'ai bien pris ça je crois
et vous en avez eu
ça été vous avez été un peu déçu de ce
qui s'est passé après non j'ai eu pas
mal de propositions mais pas forcément
des choses bon c'est vrai que comme
j'étais assez
plantureuse vous l'êtes toujours oui je
le suis toujours mais bon on m'a proposé
des choses qui me plaisaient pas
forcément qui n'allaient pas avec mon
caractère par exemple je sais pas playby
déjà mon oui des films érotiques on vous
a proposé
érotique non il y a pas très longtemps
plutôt non à ce moment-là un peu moins
parce que peut-être qu'ils se disait les
jeunes donc il pouvit et maintenant oui
plus un petit peu oui mais bon Playboy
quand ils étaient assez intéressés quoi
ça vous n'avez jamais ah non pas du tout
ça me faisait même peur je me suis dit
c'est c'est c'est un autre monde ça me
fait peur si jeune d'être élu Miss
France j'imagine que ça vous a valu tout
à l'heure parlait Patrick des des femmes
qui pouvaient le courtiser mais vous des
hommes non oui j'ai reçu aussi pas mal
de courriers bon certainement moin que
lui mais oui mais c'est vrai que aussi
des demandes en mariage mais pareil bon
des gens très gentils mais des fois un
petit peu des gens bizarres voir
satanique satanique oui ou ouais ouais
il y a quelqu'un qui a qui qui écrivait
même lorsque j'étais à Paris et des
années après une personne écrivait avec
des trucs un peu saintaniques je sais
pas c'était un peu bizarre ma mère
d'ailleurs me la cacher assez longtemps
et puis un jour elle m'a dit tu sais je
vais t'avouer quelque chose tu reçois du
courrier elle avait peur en fait j'ai
pas j'ai pas trop voulu relire le
Télégramme ni les lettres je jure que ce
n'était pas moi pareil les coup de fil
aussi un peu un peu spéci
du style quand même un décrocher oui
qu'est-ce que vous faites faire à votre
fille voulez la prostituer enfin des
trucs bizarre quoi mais pas que négatif
il y a aussi du positif des gens très
gentils qui me félicit qui voulaient des
photos dédicaces et tout je veux dire
faut pas non plus voir que le côté
négatif mais c'est vrai qu'à cette
époque là ce genre de coup de fil ou de
de lettrre m'angoissait quand même mais
ce dit vous avez dû faire fantasmer pas
mal d'hommes quand même parce
que il suffit de regarder la
la tête de Tan en 82 ouais ouais quoi
vous vous souvenez vous vous souvenez
d'elle non c'est vrai écialement mais
bon les M France c'est tous des Bolos qu
pas faut pas délirer est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas devenu femme j'ai envie de
dire avant l'heure ça nous a pas projeté
si dans le monde des adultes quand même
très vite ou oui ou ouais parce que
j'étais en jeans t-shirt basket puis
toutun coup dès le lendemain il fallait
que je porte des auut talons que je me
maquille que je porte des robes de femme
et que bon je je m'exprime justement
quand même comme une adulte je pais plus
dire je pouvais pas plus mettre mon
walkman les
rollers justement oui oui oui c'est sûr
mais bon c'est pas c'est un peu devenir
quand même une poupée Barbie je mets
entre guillemets pendant pendant une
année oui oui c'est vrai mais je crois
que vous
savez je crois que on fait rien si on en
est pas conscient donc j'ai toujours été
conscient de ce que j'ai fait et est-ce
que par la suite vous pensez que ça a
modifié le regarde des hommes sur vous
quand il savait que vous aviez été Miss
France vous l'avez caché vous le disiez
facilement
euh non oui je l'ai caché bon mais
forcément vu que par la suite j'ai fait
de temps en temps un petit clip ou des
choses comme ça forcément quelqu'un me
reconnaissait donc il me disait tiens tu
as fait ceci cela oui oui oui euh par
contre c'est vrai qu'au niveau des
hommes c'est pas forcément positif parce
que la
personne s'intéresse plutôt parce que à
vous parce que bon vous avez vous êtes
une ancienne Miss et il voit ce côté un
petit peu bon mousseux il s'intéresse
peut-être moins à la personne alors pour
la suite qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous espérez vous c'est donc devenir
comédienne oui ouais oui oui tout à fait
tout ce qu'il y a autour donc les médias
tout ce qui est autour de la starisation
tout ça vous vous aimez vous prêtez
facilement je m'y prête facilement
mais curieusement je je ne voudrais
jamais être une superstar parce que je
pense que ça doit être très
déséquilibrant non ce que j'aimerais
c'est être connu pour pour mon
travail reconnu en fait c'est le terme
c'est même pas être connu voyez c'est
être reconnu reconnu oui parce
que créer des choses je trouve ça
fabuleux quoi
c'est on existe j'ai besoin d'exister
vous avez à pressbook Sabrina oui bien
sûr oui ou mais pas curieusement bon ça
fait 12 ans
donc les anciennes photos elles sont
plutôt dans une valise un peu en retrait
parce que bon j'ai peut-être j'en a
assez de les voir peut-être ouis je su
plutôt un book
actuel pour ne rien manquer sur ma
chaîne in mire Duma abonnez-vous et
activez la
[Musique]
cloche